Hi! I'm the bus driver.
Listen, I've got to leave for a little while, so can you watch things for me until I get back?
Thanks. Oh, and remember:...
...don't let the pigeon drive the bus!
I thought he'd never leave.
Hey, can I drive the bus?
Please? I'll be careful.
I tell you what: I'll just steer.
My cousin Herb drives a bus almost every day!
True story.
Pigeon at the wheel!
No? I never get to do anything!
Hey, I've got an idea.
Let's play "Drive the Bus"!
I'll go first!
C'mon! Just once around the block!
I'll be your best friend!
How about I give you five bucks?
No fair!
I bet your mom would let me.
What's the big deal?
I have dreams, you know!
Fine.
Let me drive the bus!
I'm back!
You didn't let the pigeon drive the bus, did you?
Great.  Thanks a lot.
Bye!